[Music]  so scrolls are the bad guys  and you're a tree a race of noble  warriors heroes noble warrior heroes  [Music]  your life began the day it nearly ended  we found you with no memory we made you  one of us so you could live longer  stronger superior  you were reborn  I keep having these  memories something in my past is the key  to all of this  you're not a wladis thing we'll see  that's a yes or no question yes  [Music]  would you like to know  what you really are  I think there had a life here  what are you telling me  you come a long way  but you know as strong as you think  this war is just the beginning  I'm not going to fight your war  [Music]  I'm gonna end it  [Music]  I'm sure the cutest little thing aren't  you  what's your name  [Music]